the comedian bill burr has a new comedy
special i really like bill burr though
for me when it comes to comedy
there's norm mcdonald there was norm
mcdonald the greatest maybe the all-time
greatest and then there's sort of
everybody else so i'm not it's not like
i'm a big super fan of really any living
comedian but as far as living comedians
go i think bill burr is very very funny
and he's a pretty sharp guy and
certainly very entertaining so he's got
this new special out i haven't been able
to see the whole special but there's a
clip that has gone viral and it is a
clip in which bill burr takes on
abortion
it tells you a lot about
the moment that we're living in post
dobbs
roe v wade overruled the abortion
conversation
taking on a whole new dimension even
even the way comedy has evolved take a
listen to bill's take i don't like
people telling me what to do and i was
just like it's your body who the [ __ ]
mind to tell you what to do with your
body so that always made sense all right
however
i still think you're killing a baby
see
that's where it gets weird
like i sit on the fence and the whole
thing makes sense to me
whatever anybody's saying like don't
tell you what to do it's my body my
choice that's right man she's right
leave me a hell alone are you killing a
baby well i mean there is now
all right pause it right here
what is it right here i love the way
that he's setting this up it's similar
to the way louis ck set up abortion
which is he said look abortion i'll
clean up the language well abortion it's
just like it's just like going to the
bathroom you know you know you go get an
abortion you go to the bathroom it's
just exactly the same thing there's no
difference whatsoever or you're
murdering a baby
so he gives you the setup i'm very
pro-choice i'm very i support abortion
but does this bother you
and the pro-abortion people can't
acknowledge that that's why they use all
the euphemisms they never say
killing a baby they never call the baby
a baby they don't even use the word
abortion as much anymore so it's women's
choice
reproductive
rights yeah even though this is the
opposite of reproduction yeah it's
women's health all these euphemisms
because they can't deal with the reality
and good comedians
never shy away from the reality so
you're saying look yeah i get it he's
probably being sincere here i can't tell
if he's being totally ironic just to get
a pro-life message through reviews being
like yeah i get i get abortion yeah
that's fine i'm kind of vaguely pro but
but you know you are killing a baby
right you're not going to shy away from
that so then here's the punch line i
mean we're going to be honest and it's
the whole purpose of the procedure
you know you're not going in there
because you got an earring
you're going in there because you're
like i got a baby in me
right you walk in with a baby you come
out without one what happened to the
baby right
something can happen so
pro-choice people like well it's not a
life yet it's not a baby yet if you do i
don't know what they say before you do
the first thursday or the last tuesday
i love the way he's doing this too
because he's saying look they're saying
it's not a life yet i don't know maybe i
don't what do i know i'm not a bi but
here's here's what i know about their
arguments is their arguments are always
like well yeah it's at 15 weeks
magically for some reason at 15 weeks
you're a living human being but not at
14 weeks and six days that's why and he
just takes that to an extreme which is
yeah and then you spin around and on
tuesday morning that's right so he's
he's showing his hand a little bit more
you can start to tell okay this guy
seems to be a little bit more on the
pro-life side here now the punch line is
phenomenal first though got to tell you
about our friends over at good ranchers
in ronald reagan's farewell address he
said all great change in america begins
around the dinner table bring your
family to the dinner table with good
ranchers i really love good ranchers
when i was growing up as a kid
having steak was a special occasion kind
of a thing you know the steak at the
butcher shop it was kind of expensive
and i know i sound like an old man i we
walked up hill 15 miles both ways but it
was it was a real special occasion kind
of thing good ranchers makes it such
that you can have steak the ordinary
american family can have steak regularly
i've been eating good ranchers probably
three times a week their steaks are
extremely high quality all american meat
just magnificent magnificent stuff born
raised harvested here in the u.s they
ship it right to your door you can
actually if you subscribe you can lock
in your price so you can either just
order the meat get a box of meat that's
great the chicken's great the ribeyes
are great the t-bones the wagyu burgers
or you can subscribe lock in your price
and then you've just got it for the
lifetime of your subscription so it's
inflation-proof it's crazy
right now use my code knowles canadawlis
to get your steakhouse experience for 30
off plus free shipping on your order
shipping in general is not cheap this is
a lot of top quality meat so make sure
you take advantage of this offer go to
goodranchers.com knowles start bringing
people back to the table and eating
seriously delicious food if you already
bought from good ranchers show me what
you're making post a photo of your meal
tag me and our friends over at
goodranchers so they can see it too
it's not a baby yet that's what they say
which may or may not be true i don't
know i'm not a doctor but i'll tell you
my gut tells me that doesn't make sense
it's not a baby yet that would be like
if i was making a cake and i poured some
batter in a pan and i poured in the oven
and then five minutes later you came by
and you grabbed the pan you threw it
across the floor
and i let the
[Applause]
[Music]
it's like well it would have been
if you didn't do what you just did there
would have been a cake in 50 minutes
something happened to that change you
take murder
he's really good he's the thing about
bill bill
burr is he's i once saw him do a bit i
think it was in an opinion anthony
festival or something i saw the bit
online and he just
he can roll extemporaneously he's
clearly got really really great chops he
plays the room so well this bit was
worked out and the analogy is great here
because he's even showing sometimes
occasionally pro-life advocates will go
a little far too
and they'll say well no there's
absolutely no distinction whatsoever
between a baby at i don't know ten weeks
and six months and two years and five
years and that's not exactly true either
obviously there are physical differences
for sure and differences of development
but it's essentially the same thing
it it we we are talking about a baby at
every stage and the cake analogy i think
is great he goes yeah okay the cake at
five minutes in it's not the exact same
as the cake
at an hour
but it is my cake okay it is my cake and
if you just leave the cake in there it's
gonna be exactly like the cake that
you're picturing in your mind you cake
murdering s.o.b
the place that that you find comedy
will tell you where the culture is
moving very often this is true it goes
back to court jesters
that the court jester is the only one
who's allowed to speak truth to the king
and it's and it's very funny that's how
he can get away with it well that's the
same thing here
the establishment
the corporate
mandated top-down culture
that is just trying to suck the life out
of you in this case literally is very
pro-abortion
but the subversive elements the
counterculture all they're the ones who
are saying no hold on
hold on that's not just a clump of cells
that's not just a parasite it's not it's
a
it's a baby right can we just can we at
least get back to the place where we're
saying it's a baby
and bill bird does it
with a plum excellent job
[Music]